Fox News host Howard Kurtz admits he's
not talking about the Dominion lawsuit
against Fox News because Fox News told
him you're not allowed to talk about
this now a lot of people are making a
very very big deal out of this I'm going
to give you my view of it in a moment
Howard Kurtz does like the media
Watchdog show on Fox News the show is
pretty bad but the point here is he
brings this up Dominion is suing Fox
News over their role in promoting
conspiracy theories about Dominion
voting machines in the aftermath of the
2020 election Howard Kurtz and others on
Fox News haven't talked about it why
Howard Kurtz explains some of you have
been asking why I'm not covering the
Dominion voting machines lawsuit against
Fox involving the unproven claims of
election fraud in 2020 and it's
absolutely a fair question yes I believe
I should be covering it it's a major
media story given my role here at Fox
but the company has decided that as part
of the organization being sued I can't
talk about it or write about it at least
for now I strongly disagree with that
decision but as an employee I have to
abide by it and if that changes I'll let
you know yeah so many of you have
pointed out to me that Fox News is
completely silent about the fact that
there is this massive lawsuit and the
discovery led to the revelation of those
texts wherein we learned that Fox News
hosts who on air were pretending like
there was Merit to the things being said
by Donald Trump about the 2020 election
we're texting each other and admitting
it's all lies it's all crazy there's
nothing here it's a major story and Fox
News hasn't been talking about it now I
I have to tell you this is not the big
shocker that some are making it out to
be there is no doubt about the
newsworthiness of the sub object matter
and I'll tell you what I think no matter
what Fox News hosts wouldn't be allowed
to talk about it but
it is true
that any lawyer worth anything would
tell Fox News don't talk about this
lawsuit on the air because it can only
create more problems for you best case
scenario it doesn't help you but it
doesn't hurt you worst case scenario you
do what Alex Jones was doing daily on
his program while the defamation suit
against him was going on and you just
damage yourself so
I think no matter what like aside from
lawyers making the suggestion Fox News
has probably determined this isn't a
good thing for us to be talking about
regardless but there is no way that
lawyers aren't for Fox News aren't
saying do not talk about the lawsuit on
the air so the most you could say about
you know someone like Howard Kurtz is if
you really disagree with it that much
then you should leave
that's perfectly fair thing to say
at the same time it's expected CNN would
do the same thing MSNBC would do the
same thing in this situation it would be
quite silly to be talking about the
lawsuit Alex Jones did it and we saw how
well that went for him